The new law on the right to repair
will put money back into consumers pockets.
It will bring new life to broken appliances
and make sure that we move away from a disposable economy
to a circular economy. Throwaway culture has come to an end.
Your smartphones, your air fryer,
your bicycles can be repaired
even after the expiration of a warranty or a guarantee.
Saving 4 million tons of greenhouse gas emissions
is the equivalent of taking 2 million cars off the road.
European consumers lose almost 12 billion euro a year
in buying replacements for goods that could have been repaired.
This directive shows how the Green Deal can work for consumers
and for those of us
who have consistently voted in favour of Green Deal measures
throughout this mandate.
It is crucial that we use these positive measures
to show members of the public
that laws that protect the environment are a win win
for people and for planet. Thank you.